SKRATTAR DU!!!!!! (You laugh)
FÖRLORAR DU!!!!!! (You lose)
DUDE!!! I've tried to tell you many times
DON'T LAUGH!!!!!
ÅH! (STAN MONSTA X)
If you laugh, then you will lose
Will you accept this challenge? You've already clicked on the video (0h n0)
Lets play along, lets watch some funny videos ( No thank you I'll pass )
But let's not laugh at them if you if you lie if you laugh, you will lose. You look. Why are you going out?
I'm not even clicking
If you... Goddamn it!!
let's go everyone
"YO! LIKE THIS GAME IS SO GOSH DARN BAD BRO!"
"OH MY GOSH!!!"
"STAHHHHHHPHHH!!!!!"
"OH MY GOSH!"
"He's gonna turn up in an internet meme if he's not careful, it's okay, I called Marilyn"
"What is wrong with this GAMEEEE!!!!???!"
My god
You're playing Fifa dude, or what is it Madden? He's playing Madden
if you're gonna be mad at a game at least be mad at a real man's game
LiKe DaRkSoUlS
That's a really hard game. "Only a three-man rush"
"YO, THIS GAME IS SO GOSH DARN BAD, BRO"
*INHALE*
"OH MY GOSH!"
"STAHPPP!!!"
The classic blame it on the game, almost skratta, but no you didn't get me this time. No you did not.
Ahh! It's so good
I need to do that on Marzia
How would you not wake up. How? Oh my god. It's daylight, there's daylight outside.
How are you there passed out. Some people don't even wake up when a car drives over them
Ridiculous
Yep, that seems... Oh great
Wow what a great game, that's what this is what a...
Nintendo people expect when they're gonna play Dark Souls finally coming out on the switch
That's gonna be great. I've heard about Dark Souls. You dodge and you
You'd kill the little anime mushroom girl. Seem like a great game. I can't wait to play it
"You can't scare me with this-"
*BIG SCARE*
Yes, oh thats good
"You can't scare me with this-"
*BIG SCARE*
Come on that's a good meme I love that I love the new like edited videos or whatever "Editevomovies"
What did I just say? I'm not okay? I'm not okay. Please don't ask.
"Ready for this wait for the beat drop, whoa"
"Get ready for Futuremangaming"
"To the next level" Oh wow
Oh, that's too good. That's too good. I feel like that's almost set up, goddamnit.
Well he did get two guys so that's like a 2, to 2-1 K/D. That's not bad. That's not bad at all
"Oh, he's fucking back again. How does he always do it?"
"But fucking Solid Snake is here again"
"How the fuck?"
That's good
Good meme. Good meme, everybody
Oh, that's good
"(WAKE ME UP)"
No, no, I'm not watching that.
The pain
The suffering. My god.
Football really is the ball game of the men, the man of the, wow, it takes some tough guys look at that
CRITICAL DAMAGE! My god
How could you- how could you do this!
How could you strike my hair?!!?! I AM DEATH DAMMIT
WHY? WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS?!
"Voltaire, John Locke, Calvin, and Hobbes, all sorts of people come in and they did Renaissance"
"Renaissance is basically the history version of feels versus reals, and reals won all the time, but then some"
"Philosophers in the 1800's decided feels were better than reals, which brings me to fucking Kant"
"Kant looked at all the people using reals and he wrote a big book called:"
"'I'm not listening because this hurts my feelings'"
"He teamed up with Karl Marx Karl Marx was this guy who didn't feel like going to work on Monday"
"And he wrote a big book called:"
"'I am lazy and the government should take care of me'"
"these two lazy crybaby 'Manginas' inspired a bunch of other crybaby"
"'Manginas' who set up the Frankfurt School who recruited their team of feminists,"
"communists, and people who care about black people, and sent them off to destroy all straight, white men"
"Friedrich Nietzsche saw this bullshit and debunked all their YouTube videos with real"
"atheism and science and then their videos like dislike ratio was terrible which"
"basically means none of their shit passed peer-review."
That's true, that's true having a terrible like dislike ratio is the pinnacle of destruction you're done,
You're done, mate. If he made sure they got that many dislikes,
that's ultimate destruction right there ultimate annihilation.
"That's just a stupid boulder"
"It's not just a boulder. It's a rock (Iraq)"
Awhh, it hurts...
It's so dumb it's so dumb
That's just a stupid Boulder"
"It's not just a boulder. It's a rock (Iraq)"
God damn it
It's like you have a sneeze
Goddamn it
Good one good one. These are getting better and better
Recently when I became deathly ill I used this remote control to contact life. Call my 24-hour emergency
Medical response service watch, you just press this button and speak into the air
I'M HAVING CHEST PAIN
I love these edits, they're so good. Goddamn it. It seemed like a pretty decent service. I would love to sign up to it
Good meme that was that was great what a great meme. He's
Always clever, I'll give you that I'll give you that I give you that
Okay, all right all right. Thank you. Let's play a game. Let's play a game binky
He is standing is it a fact or an opinion that?
He is standing by mind us that stuff. That's
Definitely a fact. Yes. That's a fact
Binky what are you talking about? She is a girl is it a fact or an opinion that she is a girl?
oh
Oh
O      h
Finally some delicious food Hey look. It's another one of these
T  O  U  C  H  A   M   Y   S  P  A  H  G  E  T
Well that was the death of that meme I think we've taken it far enough, thank you well
It's a good. Good while it lasted. Oh my god. I've seen this one. It's so good
Like... shit posting a lot of memes lately...
You've been posting a lot of memes?
Yeah like really crappy ones
CRAPPY ONES?
MEMES AREN'T CRAPPY
It's like what can I cook your mom's panties?
Yeah yeah but, due to my current mood, I'm just not caring anymore
Well you should just clean this stuff out you know
You know all this stuff to make the repairs, so that's good. Yeah. What's in those other rooms? Are they're just?
What a great shit poster never seen one in the physical form before by that I always had my suspicions
Oh my god
Stop.
Stop
STOP THIS GARBAGE MEME (it's not even a meme it's just garbage)
Stop it!
STOP IT
Stop posting the stupid skideeddle skedaddle
Stupid meme
Skaddilez skadoodeletto
Maybe one day you'll be funny never never you would never be funny this meme means nothing
Don't- never touch someone's spaghet: rule number 1
Oh
Oh great
Thank you for the nightmares. Thank you very much. Let's talk about music
I dig blues music
We don't like children's music, *in unison* No, no, no
What music are YOU into?
I like this, it's very grown up:
That's dope
Good meme
All right not not super funny, but good meme I will- I appreciate it
Oh my god. I can't believe it. It was a hologram all this time
I was so immersed in that it would seem that was all the time we had for today
Did your skrata or did you flora?
Let me know in the comments or answer this poll
leave a like if you skratta that leave a like if you flora and
remember to check out some other you laughs you lose and this has been your host PewDiePie, and I will see you goodbye